a year ago they said they couldn't
believe they took kabul so easily they
celebrated then and they still are
on a now public holiday the taliban took
to the streets in their famous pickup
trucks and of course now in their
captured cars
to this conquering army nato's greatest
failure was never in doubt
they say they always knew
these enormous convoys have been going
on continuously as you can see they're
all still fully armed
i think what the message from the
taliban to the outside world is we're
here we're still armed and we're here to
stay
[Music]
exactly a year on the taliban continued
a new tradition of a televised media
event open to the international media
but overwhelmingly attended by loyalists
special forces soldiers struggle to hold
back people eager to get inside
and seems somewhat at a loss what to do
with women
in the audience taliban royalty
including anas haqqani
a powerful 28 year old leader and
negotiator with the united states in
doha
his arrival sparked a flurry of activity
by the press corps eager for pictures of
him by chance he sat behind me and we
started chatting
he told me economically afghanistan is
struggling because foreign aid has been
slashed and assets frozen
the key sticking point with the
international community is education for
girls
in his interview with sky news he hinted
at compromise but explained it would
take time to convince the taliban's old
guard saying the world must give him
some room
this is nuanced stuff but for a haqaani
family member an ultra conservative
group this is a big deal
how the world deals with the taliban in
the future is undecided of course
for the foot soldiers celebrating
outside the now mothballed american
embassy a symbol of a failed campaign to
change afghanistan none of this really
matters right now
[Music]
in truth many of these taliban were
babies when the war started
a trillion dollars and 21 years later
they're in total control
stuart ramsey sky news kabul